[Music]
how's it feel being here but really say
I'm excited I'm excited yes I haven't
been in a while for us I love watching
from home but it's nothing like just
being here and feeling the energy seeing
all my friends all my fears and I loved
watching it at TV and looking at my two
Grammys on the mantel but I can't wait
so I could get one more hello artists
yes I love that we got to talk about
Beyonce she every talk of the town
tonight is are you ready for this
performance
I am excited for it it's the first of
all she's superwoman the fact that she's
performing pregnant with twins it's just
a whole nother thing in itself um but
you know what she's so good yeah I
didn't expect anything different and she
always brings it she does yeah yeah it's
gonna be different it's gonna be
creative it's gonna be everybody's gonna
try and copy it next week or tomorrow
yeah whatever she does but I'm excited
for her were you guys blown away by the
pregnancy announcement after the rest of
the year I was like wind I just we um we
just caught up with each other on her
last tour oh yeah and I think it was a
San Francisco date and of course you
that big
I was like wait okay so this was happen
shortly thereafter but I'm so excited
for her I'm so excited for her so when
you guys talk about on your last to her
house cuz she delays in the bees world
she doesn't talk to us oh yes she does
Abby has been very I feel like she's
been a lot more open and I love that
people are getting a chance to see her
personality she's such a wonderful
person
the phenomenal mom phenomenal wife of
course when I'm the hardest Entertainer
period but when we catch up it's the how
you doing how you mama doing I should
run the door oh my god you get so big
little girl stuff just like we just had
our girl moment huh it's the same thing
and she's you know always telling me how
proud she is of me the last time we we
caught up she's like me ever mom just
called about you a couple of days ago so
happy for you and that's just that warms
mom you don't know right yeah I want so
much fun tonight
I'm graduations on everything and
everything to back to life it's out
right now I just released some music I'm
also in Rosewood Fox TV show and
rosewood but back to life is out right
now shooting up the charts the video is
out as well on VEVO and YouTube so check
it out